When you think of Venom, you usually think
of the symbiote's main squeeze — Eddie Brock.
But another character from Venom lore is making
waves in movies now. Let's peel back the untold
truth of She-Venom, from her dark origins in
comic books to her life on the silver screen.
Anne Weying debuted in 1993's
"The Amazing Spider-Man" #375.
A lawyer once married to Eddie Brock, Anne
is approached by Spider-Man to help track
down her ex-husband, who's kidnapped Peter
Parker's seemingly-resurrected parents.
With Anne's help, Spider-Man manages to
trace Venom to an old haunt of Eddie's,
the Thrill World amusement park. Anne secretly
tags along and tries to appeal to Venom's sense
of reason, but she's interrupted when Eddie
is attacked by Silver Sable's Wild Pack.
While Venom and Spider-Man
fight the Pack together,
Anne helps Peter's parents (who turn out to
be robots built by the fiendish Chameleon)
escape. She then returns to
rescue Eddie from being killed.
Things take a dire turn when a damaged
Ferris wheel almost falls on Anne,
but Venom, with Spider-Man's help, manages
to rescue her in time. She proceeds to point
out that Spider-Man wouldn't have tried
to rescue her if he were a bad person,
which finally convinces Venom to stop terrorizing
his longtime foe ... for a while, anyway.
Anne Weying next appears in the 1995 miniseries
"Venom: Sinner Takes All." In this story,
she gets shot by a new version of the
villainous Sin-Eater. Anne ends up hospitalized,
but is soon whisked away by Venom when the
Sin-Eater tracks her down to finish the job.
The trip to Venom's underground hideout
reopens Anne's stitched-up wounds,
which leads Eddie to try healing
her by sharing his symbiote.
When that isn't enough, Eddie tells the alien
suit to separate from him for the time being,
so it can bond with Anne
completely. Thus, She-Venom is born.
As She-Venom, Anne manages to save Eddie
from two criminals who find his lair.
She does this by violently killing them,
however, prompting a horrified Eddie to
blackmail the alien into releasing
Anne and merging with him again.
By that point, Anne is fully healed, but she is
horrified by her actions as She-Venom, especially
once Eddie reveals that the symbiote can't
actually force a person to act against their will.
Disgusted by both the symbiote and what it's
revealed about herself, Anne shuns Eddie for
making the alien suit bond with her in their first
place. Despite this, in the series' final issue,
Anne briefly becomes She-Venom once again
to rescue Eddie from a sticky situation.
Despite her mixed feelings toward her
ex-husband and his symbiote "friend,"
Anne Weying isn't interested in
getting Eddie Brock arrested.
Unfortunately, she still ends up being
forced to cooperate with the police
when they attempt to capture her ex in
1996's "Venom: Along Came A Spider."
Anne gives Eddie a subtle heads-up when he
tries to call her, leading Eddie's symbiote
to travel through her phone receiver and
temporarily turn Anne into She-Venom once again.
This time, however, the symbiote
remains partially attached to Eddie,
leading to a euphoric experience in which Eddie
and Anne experience each other's memories.
Venom rescues Anne from police headquarters,
but she is eventually arrested
for acting as his accomplice.
Eddie's symbiote travels to Anne by telephone
once more, this time bonding with her fully.
She-Venom proceeds to go to Thrill
World, in the hopes of meeting Eddie,
but she finds it's become a hideout for crime
boss L.D. 50 and his associates. A showdown
between She-Venom, Ben Reilly's Spider-Man,
the police, and L.D. 50's gang breaks out,
during which Anne gives Eddie the symbiote
to heal him from injuries ... but not before
getting her fair share of punches and kicks
(not to mention green slobber) in as She-Venom.
After L.D. 50's defeat, Eddie admits he still
loves Anne, who states she'd only consider letting
him back into her life if he put his hatred for
Spider-Man and reliance on symbiotes behind him.
Since her debut, Anne Weying has always
made it clear that she cares about Eddie,
even if they're on the outs. The details
of how and when they broke up, however,
seem to vary from comic to comic. 1997's
"Uncanny Origins" #7 suggests that Eddie's
narcissism is what ended their marriage,
and that they broke up before Eddie was
fired from the Daily Globe newspaper for
mistaking an imposter for the Sin-Eater.
It also makes minor changes to how Venom
was reformed, having him and Spider-Man
save Anne from a falling wall in the city,
rather than a Ferris wheel at a theme park.
2008's "Venom: Dark Origin" suggests things
happened even more differently. It depicts
Anne and Eddie as still being married when
his inaccurate story about the Sin-Eater
was published. It also implies that it was
Eddie's obsession with success that drove
a wedge between him and Anne, eventually
leading to their divorce. Eddie's constant
blaming of Spider-Man for his problems,
including his firing, didn't help either.
Anne Weying has always liked
being She-Venom a little too much,
and that terrifies her. By the time her story
reaches 1999's "Amazing Spider-Man" #19,
Anne has become afraid to even leave her home,
in case the symbiote appears and tries to bond
with her once more. A poorly-timed visit from
Eddie Brock, who wants to get back together
with her so he can regain some sense of normalcy,
makes things even worse. Anne's panic flares to
further heights when she sees Spider-Man swing
by her apartment window in his black costume.
Yet what truly ends up being the last straw
for Anne is seeing Eddie transform into Venom
to pursue the wall-crawler. This makes Anne
realize that the symbiote isn't with Spider-Man,
despite his all-black look — it's right
in front of her. After Venom leaves, Anne,
mortified by the whole experience, leaps from her
apartment to her death. When Venom returns and
sees what's happened, he swears revenge, thinking
Anne's earlier glimpse of Spider-Man is to blame.
Though Anne Weying has passed away,
her legacy lives on in a son with
Eddie Brock's DNA that the symbiote impregnated
her with during one of her stints as She-Venom.
"You serious?"
Believing she won't be able to raise the child
due to her growing paranoia over the symbiote,
Anne forces herself to leave her apartment
and give the baby to her father-in-law,
Carl Brock, in 2019's "Venom" #12.
Though Anne vows she'll return for her son, she
dies before she can make good on her promise,
leading Carl to raise him as his own.
Neither Anne nor Carl tells Eddie about the
boy. Eddie doesn't manage to meet him until
he arrives wounded (and mind-controlled by the
Venom symbiote) at his father's home. Dylan
and Eddie are initially completely
ignorant of their true connection,
nor are they aware that Anne unknowingly
transferred the piece of the Venom
symbiote still in her genes to Dylan,
granting him unique powers. Eventually,
however, they learn the truth, and Eddie
begins taking care of his long lost son.
Anne Weying and Eddie Brock are two very different
people. Yet for some reason, the Venom symbiote
seems to like merging with Anne almost as
much as it likes bonding with Eddie Brock.
An answer, of sorts, to this confounding
riddle is finally given in 2020's "Venom:
The End," which asserts that Anne
Weying is one of the universe's most
suitable beings for bonding with the
symbiote, outside of Eddie Brock.
Not only that, her compatibility's
right on par with that of Tel-Kar,
a warrior from the Kree Empire who served as the
Venom symbiote's first host, long before the alien
suit ever met Anne Weying or Eddie Brock. Unlike
Tel-Kar, however, who had to rely on scientific
enhancement to bond with the symbiote, Anne's
high compatibility level is completely natural.
It's never exactly explained why Anne meshes
so well with the symbiote, although it might be
because, as "Venom: Sinner Takes All" shows, she
can be just as bloodthirsty as Eddie when pushed.
In one alternate reality, Anne Weying becomes
She-Venom under very different circumstances.
As detailed in 2020's "Venom" issues #27
and #28, this Anne is the one who bonds with
Venom in a dark cathedral, rather than Eddie
Brock, who is already dead in this universe.
What's more, She-Venom eventually transforms into
Agent Venom, the identity Spider-Man's longtime
friend and ex-bully Flash Thompson assumes in the
main Marvel Universe. Not long after Anne becomes
Agent Venom, her suit produces several other
symbiotes. This is possibly to prepare for this
Earth's conquest by Codex, a corrupted version
of Anne's son, Dylan, and his symbiote armada.
This version of Anne meets the main Marvel
Universe versions of Eddie and Dylan Brock
when they're accidentally teleported into
her universe. The three team up with Anne's
underground group of symbiote resistance
soldiers to defeat Codex and free the Earth.
Anne Weying also makes an appearance
in Marvel Comics' Earth-311 continuity,
in which all of the Marvel superheroes
are active in the year 1602. She shows
up in the second issue of "1602 Witch Hunter
Angela" as the bride-to-be of one Edwin Brocc.
Unfortunately, this version of Weying
isn't marrying Brocc for his personality,
but because Brocc has used the Enchantress'
magical elixir to hypnotize her. Luckily,
Witch Hunter Angela and Serah Anchorton
save Weying from marrying Brocc,
who soon loses his head to Angela's
sword when he tries fighting her and
Serah as a red, four-legged creature that,
unsurprisingly, looks kind of like Venom.
It's hard to say to what extent "Venom: Dark
Origin" is canon to the Marvel Universe,
as it doesn't always 100% square with
past events. If the parts that don't
contradict anything are in continuity,
though, then Anne Weying and Eddie Brock
both went to a very famous college in
Marvel lore: Empire State University.
Though it only exists in the comics, unlike the
very real SUNY Empire State College in Saratoga
Springs, New York, with which it's sometimes
confused, ESU counts many famed Marvel characters
among its alumni and faculty. Luminaries
including Norman Osborn, the Human Torch,
Curt Connors, and Emma Frost have all walked
its hallowed halls at one point or another.
The character most associated with Empire
State University, however, is Peter Parker,
aka Spider-Man. Though Anne Weying is never shown
meeting Peter at ESU, she does meet Eddie there
in "Venom: Dark Origin." She starts a
relationship with him some time after
Eddie takes credit for stopping a gang who
attacked them both on the street. Who really
rescued Anne Weying and Eddie Brock, you might
ask? Why, none other than Spider-Man, of course.
Venom has appeared in all kinds of
Spider-Man adaptations over the years,
including multiple cartoons
and three live-action movies.
Yet somehow, She-Venom, who has a strong
connection to Eddie Brock and his symbiote,
hadn't appeared in any Spider-Man movies
or television series until 2018's "Venom."
Admittedly, she came somewhat close
in 2012's "The Amazing Spider-Man," as
Anne Weying is said to be Curt
Connors' lawyer, but she's never shown.
Thankfully, the live-action "Venom"
movie corrects that oversight with style.
"I just bit that guy's head off."
Overall, Anne Weying isn't changed
too much in her on-screen debut:
She practices law and has a
romantic history with Eddie.
Unlike the comics, however, the two break
up before they have the chance to marry,
as Eddie's snooping as a journalist
unintentionally torpedoes Anne's legal career.
When the Venom symbiote possesses Eddie, Anne
becomes one of his staunchest allies, even
becoming She-Venom to save Eddie's life. The two
share a kiss while Anne is She-Venom, though they
don't fully rekindle their relationship, as she
has moved on and is dating Dr. Dan Lewis instead.
Anne and Eddie's paths cross again in
"Venom: Let There Be Carnage," however,
as any Venom fan might have guessed they would.
These two can't escape each other that easily.
"Oh, that's bullsh-t!"
Check out one of our newest videos
right here! Plus, even more Looper
videos about your favorite comic book
heroes and villains are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.